[Music]
like how am i sounding well here we are
hot boxing Mike hell yeah brother where
you got the garment Lords in the house
Cody and Zach daiquiri what's up guys a
sweet life Cody obviously a tremendous
UFC fighter also we're going to get into
your book that packed a little bit talk
about your relationship with Maddox
maple and Zach you're out there in West
Virginia dude running the show we're
gonna hop into that a little bit and
talk about that next great Tyson
endeavor hell yeah dude that'll be huge
to have that hemp grown well let's start
there Zach tell us about so in West
Virginia we've got a huge hemp grow
operation that's gonna be give us access
and and supply of a ton of really
high-quality CBD tell us a little bit
about what's going on out there
yeah we took over a 350 thousand square
foot under the my clip brother 350,000
square foot greenhouse we're playing a
half of all the farmers in West Virginia
growing clones for us buying the biomass
back off them we have the first
extraction equipment in the state
looking to do probably uh 1800 pounds a
day of biomass extracted it was how take
it off the Mike's so I don't pull your
guys eardrums out yeah man so uh a lot
of things going on there that's awesome
and so we're working with West Virginia
University mm-hmm we are working with
some leading legislators there some
politicians yes till just lay the right
groundwork for that operation correct
that's awesome it's great to see you
great to have you back in town or did
you guys go to dinner oh yeah Mike then
stay for dessert
I know I thought you were staying the
next he knows her he's like yeah he had
a second guessin he got out of there
left all this desert I'm like what
happened Mike you got scared
we got the cheese Kay we got this
pumpkin put crazy stuff oh it was good
definitely uh went off my diet
hey man sometimes you gotta have to
pumping out push-ups when I got here I
started my morning all wrong
these are doing something in the morning
hey man that's my my morning routine
yoga meditation we were talking about
that earlier I hit about 20 to 30
minutes of yoga and then if I'm not
gonna get a lift in I make sure to hit
about you know one to two hundred
push-ups nice and then I'm doing these
crazy breathing exercises the whole time
so people might see me and they're like
what's going on with you man but I'm
like yeah and I'm just getting
oxygenated you can get high off your own
breath it's pretty dope yeah activate
your endocannabinoid system watch the
wim hof that you exact them off as the
man yeah where I learned that yeah
that's awesome you know with your breath
but definitely knows with fighting
football training you're eating it's you
have to have a a good system so Cody
we're gonna talk about your book cuz I
think it's a pretty amazing story but
something I read about you I didn't know
you were an all-state linebacker in high
school yeah yeah actually played
football with my brother he was always
bigger and faster and stronger than me I
was so smart eating at the pantsing and
fit when we fry played in first grade
the helmet was like a bobblehead like a
little giant oh my god
so that's always one of the place that
was a you know good good photo player
bigger than me so he was a fullback and
so I went out for football I was boxing
and I was you know I'm gonna go out it
was his senior year my junior went out
for football didn't play I took like
freshman sophomore off and say I'm gonna
play our last year together and played I
was the outside linebacker at 140 pounds
and I was gonna wobble it's me off that
edge and I would fly off oh yeah I leave
my torpedo come up with stingers all the
time you know yeah but I had a had a
blast and you know becoming Ohio and it
was great you know then abseil I was
running back for him it's easy when Zach
just blows through a hole and I make a
quick cut and we're off to the races but
is great Zach was fullback
here's fullback man I remember one hell
yeah bro yeah you see that I would grab
my jersey and just let it like let him
just go through the hole that I would
make it cut and be off to the races but
this lets wanted to see though yeah we
have you have some highlights to put up
on youtube or on my page but this one
game I literally scored five touchdowns
and I remember this one touchdown and I
didn't exactly and I scored me you know
it was a long run he made the hole and I
didn't chest bump him first
and a guy might grab me by the face mask
he's a crazy little prick he's like you
just bought me first I'm the one
blocking for your ass and I was like
what is like after you may like yeah
yeah I'm all the way down at the you
know the end zone Zach was this hog joke
and you know just wait for you to get
all the way down the field to celebrate
huh I let my house out you know hey man
hey so our quarterback kind of like
break us up the Weiner getting a flag on
the against each other oh my god yeah
that's some insane brother [ __ ] right
there what did you guys did you guys
fight a lot growing up oh all the time
all the time yeah we our last fight was
I was 17 I remember because I had a I
had a toughest fight with him and he
gave my left cauliflower ear yeah he hit
me so hard my ear swelling cauliflower
yeah
bad guy yeah so we were out there you
know fighting for a while we drove on a
dirt road called the pump house it's in
the book you know those are Lattimer
it's their last fight and we'd always
take out-of-towners there you know kind
of country small town [ __ ] like yeah the
cops don't see you fighting in the
street she got to the pump house for you
know people are usually doing back rows
burning joints or you know anything like
that so it's some like it's real country
[ __ ] right getting out there and we had
rules like no takedowns like just stand
up you know knock him out and you know
knock him down was this to settle
something or this sandwich I had a box
of next dance tiles from cutting weight
and I was making sure I'm sorry I know I
ate this half of the sub that's what I
can eat after my workout and I'll be
good to my weigh-ins and he ate it and I
told my grandma you know the grandma
don't let anyone eat it and I see Zack
with the wrappers they grabbed his
stomach this [ __ ] was good
so I started fighting like in our
grandma's kitchen and she was like
trying to break up she twirled sweet
lady like just I didn't wanted something
happen so I ended up stopping exactly
reach over my grandmom powerbomb me on
my neck I like crushed my skull Larry
bit about bit my tongue off so like
screw this we're going out to the pump
house Diana I go outside start kicking
his truck doors and he jumps in his
truck I jump in my truck we drive I
already knew where he's going to the
left at the stoplight and she had to
fight this for the pump out okay so that
was always good I was always faster than
my Bob and we didn't that's the only
time I really hurt Zack in my entire
life
really right hit him with this overhand
right and it kind of gave him the stanky
leg and he looked at me as like good hit
you little [ __ ] and I was like ah [ __ ]
he kept coming in after that fight like
dude we're gonna kill each other you
know we got to calm it down and that was
the last time I thought because it was
like that was our fight the words again
we both got each other there's a long
fight we're there forever I remember our
peewee football coach drove by and he
was burning a joint and sauce had the
best hold the next week he's like boys
he came up to us he's and he's real
motion music boys he goes I cried I saw
you guys fighting he goes that was the
best damn fight ever want
it's crazy so you know it it definitely
said that and we kind of put into our
minds like dude we're gonna we're gonna
hurt each other I mean I got caught fire
from it yeah
and I had to fight the next day at a
boxing match you had a real fight and i
real fight the next day with it let me
cuz my knuckles were all cut up and I
was like God told him I was working on
the farm you know I was working on them
it's sitting I got it yeah some of the
tractor or something could cut up
bailing hair throw him some excuse and I
call this country kid up here and in
Cleveland Ohio fighting me okay we'll
let him go dude yeah how'd you do in
that fight one it was well that was one
of my toughest fights too like I would
fight before with Zack that's the time
that I got hit pride the hardest this
kid hit me with this stand up left hook
and I went deaf I remember well yeah I
went definitely I was good everything
was fine I just couldn't hear the crowd
was like you know Briggs you go he rung
my bell for a whole round and I come
back and sit in the corner and I'm like
oh man my oak was yelling out all these
Stephan's I can't hear I can't hear you
know I can't do that the dude hit me so
hard I can't hear and he's okay yeah
he's doing okay trying just like control
my breathing I was like I'm good well
and I was like went after a third round
and finally like as soon as I got kind
of got up and the ground started my
hearing came back I was like oh [ __ ] and
I was I was deaf or a good while round I
was deaf crazy Bell was running that bad
and we know I went won the fight and it
was a fight of the night so but I think
that fight was a lot harder because I
had to fight Zack the day before you
know yeah what are you doing
Zack was that the fight I I saw an
interview with you are you talking about
one of your guys fights was that the
fight where you're like this kid I've
got a lot of respect for this kid now I
mean obviously you had worked something
out in that fight um with him yeah yeah
man he was the first time I you ever
like he had some power I was like oh man
oh [ __ ] I didn't expect it was so fast
could he hit me like a three three shot
at that landed it kind of caught me off
guard like oh my knees my knee wobbled I
was okay I'm like oh no way and he's
kind of he kind of hesitated I think it
was he shot that shocked him to write it
hit me cuz if he had I got him one more
off he was gonna knock me out
that's gonna have to fall over yeah I
mean I was gonna have to trip or fall
down yeah yeah I was going for the kill
oh you're the killer yeah I saw him hurt
I was like oh [ __ ] this is my shot this
isn't this is my chance right here to
get him my whole entire life fighting
and he's always bigger like man there's
some time sangwich yeah yeah you never
eat my sandwich I ain't gonna eat my
salmon ever so last week
Mike and I talked about this after Mike
got back from India and he had a chance
to go and visit these slums and he said
that you know the best fighters in the
world come out of the slums I came out
of the slums Mike obviously grew up in
one of the toughest parts of Brooklyn
you guys grew up in a really tough part
of Ohio talk a little bit about the
adversity you saw as a kid Cody and you
know how that really molded you into the
fighter that you are not even even
beyond just the physical fighter you
know and having this dream of being in
the UFC but your mindset as a person
because you've got a lot of wisdom in
you and you're not you know you're a
young guy I think that's a contribute to
my mother and the practice that she
taught us and her putting us in sports
at a young age knowing that was a kind
of a way out you know that's something
that I think that she saw with her
brother too that he was good at sports
but he couldn't stay out the trouble you
know I mean so yeah I think that she
just did instill that discipline and
that hard work and a dedication to you
know show up the practice you know why
kids are out playing you're going to
wrestling camps or and she would I think
that we valued our time with her mom so
much that we realized at a young age
that it was more than just our dreams
you know it's hers and and it was us
together so spend that time her packed
up in the vans genre across the country
to the wrestling matches national
tournaments wrestling camp - and just
just seeing that it was well you know a
product of our environment is zero in a
positive light you know because
obviously talk about negative and the
upbringing is that we didn't have you
know but we did have some positive there
and I think that's truly separated us
from da another statistic or stayin
in that town not reaching our full
potential as humans it was our mother
and her drive and her dedication to make
us you know to our full ability as
humans I love that man mom's great yeah
she also kick your ass yeah yeah I mean
I believe yeah it's clear she used to
say I brought you in this world take you
out yeah Saharan brother
choking Zach at one time mama garber and
choking Mountain like I brought you in
this book whispering Broca's in this
world we take you out and like just let
his body go and like I keep trying to
come back to and I was sitting at the
dinner table wouldn't see her and I was
like oh [ __ ] I don't know how I don't
know we were buying that with teenagers
maybe maybe younger and he like bad
talked her you know I mean he'd never do
that I wasn't all me oh I'm just waiting
for it waiting for the wrath
you know it's down you know we have
never stepped down our line and I'm
forever grateful for the teachings that
she gave to us because she had to be the
mother and the father you know I feel
that wasn't there and you know we had we
were adopted by her her ex-husband now
but you know so our father figure wasn't
there so she had to give us a tough love
rule yeah and like my consequences of
getting in trouble was you not a you
know the police action or the school
action suspending you was what my mom
was gonna do that that was she's above
every law yeah I mean like I said she
can take it she brought you in this
rowing taking around she meant that [ __ ]
that's amazing man I mean that's [ __ ]
that's some amazing way to set a gym I'm
great
Jim I'm gonna beat your ass oh my God my
mom you know my parents got divorced
when I was really little I was seven and
by the time I was probably eight or nine
I was already bigger than my mom my
mom's like five too and she used to just
[ __ ] beat my ass with a wiffle ball
bat dude that was that was a you know
and she disciplined the [ __ ] out of us I
got the you know so far so pin the mouth
for curse and then we got that it was
brutal
you know the wiffle ball bat it was the
same you know it was like everything
tracks
Oh amazing track yeah you talking about
him yeah I remember one time I tried to
play hooky from school and this is this
is out never I always didn't wanted to
go to school after this I was always me
I think that's why I get up on time and
I'm like yeah Pramod on that my mother
you know [ __ ] she's berry good night you
better be in the van when it went ready
to take off and I heard her I was like
how she's not gonna make the other kids
you know late at the time I didn't know
but I understand now she had all these
kids that get to school on time and get
him ready to get him getting fed like it
was a lot you know what I'm sitting here
you know being a prick about not going
trying to fight her not going to school
I don't want to go to school that day
and hear the door shut and then the next
thing you know hit the horn honk oh my
gosh she's not gonna she's gonna take
off and I'm stealing my bullet cereal
and just like I'm gonna have a half day
I'll go have a look and she comes in
that door I heard I'm just I just I was
just frozen what did you like do I eat
the cereal cuz I wanna choke on it she
gonna come after me like what the [ __ ]
do I do like I do I run and make it
worse and I'm gonna get me one way I did
sat there and she came around that turn
kicked me up by my throat slammed me
down open my eyelids open my mouth spit
a loogie in my mouth he said you asked
walks to school and you better be there
and I was like holy oh [ __ ] around
school hey I'm gonna walk around school
that morning after I walked to school I
was like it's only even looks at me
wrong I'm [ __ ] them up like they're
getting him they're getting this raft
and like luckily I didn't get into any
[ __ ] my mom can't pick me up at lunch
took me to Dairy Queen you know so they
got tough love like Wow I mean like yeah
you know he's she had she had to do that
to us because we were we were hellions
man yeah we were crazy
that's cringe-worthy isn't it both
[ __ ] is about he's sick I heard the
story a thousand times yeah that's
really oh yeah tell you what I was made
sure it was I not it was I ever late for
school after that never one person I was
ready to go mom okay I got you
also just brought the car for you
did ya hold she tried to hear me with
the car oh yeah she was mad I wrecked
the lawnmower which I did I did hit this
like dog chain and it was buried wrapped
it up and I called him okay listen in
the new mower I messed up sorry and see
I hear you scream on the phone I'm like
oh man so I'm out there trying to get
this dog chain off this I'm trying to
lift this riding lawnmower up and get
this dog chained at the same time all
before she gets here well it doesn't
happen and I see her I can hear her
coming down the road on the call shoot
man I have something like in between the
garage and the house was the mower and
me standing there and I hear it come
around the turn tires squealing and she
doesn't even like she's like still
flying coming in the driveway
no [ __ ] well she blew right through the
driveway it's coming right at me I dive
out of the way and she hit the brakes
and the car slides past where I was
standing and I get up and she's laughing
her ass off and Cody's in there like you
know he's like oh my god she's
hysterically laughing I'm over like man
you you were definitely hit me she's
like I wouldn't have I'm like you slid
past where I was at if I didn't jump
she's got knew you would I'm like what
if I didn't yeah it was good but like
you said product environment I think
that's why we add that hard work
dedication because we we show I set us
out so I said no have fun with it make
sure you love to do it you know if you
if you start something you're gonna
finish you're not gonna quit a lot of
the kids would quit midseason or for
sure they didn't start and the parents
to come in complaining so why is this
kid quarterback he sucks yeah I mean
like ya mama just let us work and work
for the position just like you know I
love that too I think that's why I love
we excelled at wrestling so much because
it's such an individual sport yeah as
far as you know football is too into it
for sure the wrestling was always on you
winner lot win or lose it was on you you
know I mean and I think that's what we
love wrestling so much she always made
us go to the practice so I think that
going back to that I like and all the
crazy stories out there mama we love you
we were successful yeah sure yeah we
appreciate your appreciated Tupac voice
I was she doing he's great oh great yeah
she's we gotta go see yep in Ohio just
got a hunter husband my stepdads amazing
amazing person they they got a farm out
there and
their mom was doing the farm life and
got a lot of animals my little sister's
is an animal lover I mean everything I
mean she could have Ronald McDonald farm
she would you know that's my mom loves
it so horses neigh horses like wow no
cows they have hogs pigs goats bunnies
oh I love goats organic chickens yeah
they're so I we went to this the pumpkin
patch with my daughter a couple days ago
and they've got a petting zoo there
they've got the little goats I just fall
in love with them I'm ready to [ __ ]
take one home little kick each other
down and [ __ ] bounce off each other it's
crazy good stuff well before we get to
Maddox maple I got to say you two guys
have some of the best [ __ ] tattoos
I've ever seen yeah yeah yeah guys have
some unbelievable artwork is it the same
tattoo artist pull up for the most part
yeah I mean we've been getting tattooed
I think my first tattoo is 13 is 14
no more go after mom into it we like
just how'd your mom feel about the tats
I mean she took us you know oh she the
Tori Tori we had a say with me once to a
state title or a national title we go
get tattooed and like for a whole year
we were bringing out from the library
print off tattoos like Oh what about
this one mom like hey you know I want to
get that title move your ass laughs
we're gonna get that tattoo so she's
gonna wind up you know going and you
know even become national champions both
that year and you know getting tattoos
what was her first tattoo my first
tattoo is still on my back inside and
finish I'm hoping my back piece soon but
I gotta cross with a ribbon tied around
it yeah yeah sounds my first one that's
the soul at first one yeah right like
what was your first one
my cover it up nice that's the thousand
eight in the 80s yes Bob had that Bob
had Bob Filner's arm Tammany's yeah what
about you
I got across my thigh okay that was the
first time yeah absolutely god can judge
me yeah he wasn't he was in the chair
like this him go first he's like [ __ ]
man this shit's about to hurt you know I
mean I'm holding on to the chair broke
out in hives my first time really
yeah cover and I never had highs in my
life I know what was wrong my back to
nerves can't I don't know like now I did
get tattooed my glands swell up my body
like every time every time did I get
tattooed even no matter where I at my
body my glands in my like you know hips
my armpits swell up it's crazy really my
nerves I don't know my nervous system
can't handle it interesting that's a
nice fan Mike you probably had the most
famous tattoo though for sure I was
recognizable tattoo in the world have to
do well it's part of your persona now
yeah it's just who you are man you know
yeah I don't think people really realize
it either my first dad is this
dreamcatcher nice good when I was 18 it
was number one for me like Evans arms of
our back piece he's arms so you can put
so much on there yeah sound like good I
want to get some more I only get this
arm sleeved up I got to finish this a
little bit
the shaman needs a little shading it's
conjuring the White Buffalo we got to
get tattooed on the podcast man yeah
while we're doing it we gotta get Teddy
you call your guy yeah yeah dude at all
want you one-stop shop here at the Tyson
ranch you got the podcast at at shop you
got the barber shop through the workout
workouts push-up stations out back oh
yeah what about some hand tats head I
might be down for some hands yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah this fella that's a tough
spot
my stomach was my worst by far really my
was your face the worst stomach - yeah
my sister was the worst man I was like
she knows that was the worst one that's
tough yeah all right so the pact act you
met a kid named Maddox maple tell us how
did you come to meet this guy actually
was through Zack my brother I was living
out in Cleveland Tran and a gym up there
and getting ready for when I was just an
amateur fighter trying to find my way to
the pro ranks and become world champion
so I was going moving you know I have my
city and trying to go and further myself
and better myself so I kind of stayed
out of the small town talk but and you
know obviously staying with Zack Zack
was working in a coal mine in the area
so he was still around the small town
talk knew the everything that was going
on would keep me in for him like oh man
Johnny dude he's back in jail you know
talk me up we talked and and he said hey
man you should do a hear about that
Maddox family and the maple family and I
said no I didn't any explained it to me
it was just the family this five year
old was diagnosed with leukemia you know
it's like I hit me and just right in the
feelgood's because I have a sister the
same age as Maddox and it kind of just
you know it's for whatever what has just
first spoke about it kind of just hit me
right there was not even knowing the
family knowing the child and he say you
should do like a benefit your next fight
you should donate the the tickets and
the sell shirts and get to town you know
kind of the back his fight and then met
the family after two weeks he came back
I was able to have visitors after he is
you know first dose of chemo and he was
cleared to get home and just start the
process of fighting this horrible
disease and so I come there and I see
this little kid him he looks you know
just his whole world was 360 you know
spun around and yeah you know was going
in for a burst appendix he thought you
know what you know he's got trach and a
port his chest he's getting his first
dose of chemo so yeah and I look at the
kid I'm gonna say man this kid he had
you know big beautiful eyes I mean just
but I just tell he had that bad look you
can tell when you look at Mike when he
fights me look at these other fighters
that are great you see that look before
battle and that glossed over look like
determination you know I focus I saw
that and I was like man
knew that I said to the parents after I
got to know him you know like I just I
just I know this kid's gonna beat this
disease I just get I can just tell he's
he's a warrior I can just you know you
know I can just I can just feel that and
you know meaning that that time I'm
gonna stay with him learn a story we did
the the benefit the you know donations
to his family and just stayed in touch
with like like reaching out them he
would come to all my fight to his goal
was to walk me out to one of my fight
that's what he wanted to do but he was
never healthy enough he kept the chemo
kept hurting his legs he was in a
wheelchair things like that so finally
my third fight professional fight I'm
sorry my third professional fight this
is three three and a half years um
knowing the kid we've done well the
amateur career I started my pro career I
moved out this is when I moved out to
California he hadn't walked me down my
third professional fight and becoming he
was coming at all my fight so I started
as an amateur with him and then took him
to all my profiles family started coming
and it was nice it's a great bond and
you know that we've had a sponsor
ironically I got kicked out of this guys
club when I was a teenager for beating
up his bouncer and he kicked me out and
yeah but he was super cool man I'm
writing on my like I had a fan page
Facebook you know like I'll start a
career like follow me of my fan page oh
and he messaged me on there and said you
know hey the cops came I told him I
destroyed the the video so what happened
he's like you know you know you know he
knew from my you know being a good
athlete an area you know have a name
mean Zach won state title so it's got a
small town everyone you know saying C's
know when you get in trouble I just you
know when you do well so I was kind of
like started getting to like wake up
calling up getting stabbed at a bar like
I was just doing some wrong things you
know yeah I kind of like I had shot
glimpses up I promise with good fights
like all this kid's got he's gonna do it
you know right and which fall back into
that that system your negativity of that
I think that's that self doubt that your
mind plays inside yourself that you kind
of sometimes that inner voice I wants to
you know hold you back yeah you know I
would would step back am I good enough
am I can't I had because my surrounding
people all around with yeah they were
always constantly can you
make this infighting can you why you go
to college I left college twice I'm like
sitting there like I'm a failure cuz I
withdrew from college twice and you know
was listening to everyone else tell me
go get a degree and do this fighting
you're not gonna meet you're not gonna
amount to nothing with us until I
finally you know fulfilled my self
purpose and followed my dreams you know
it started everything started lining up
like this is Maddox I'm never thinking
like reaching out to his family and
doing that would we'd have them singers
speaking with you Evan and Mike and my
brother and talking about a book that we
did together so moving forward from that
just I started doing sorry everything
started lying in my life and my career
start taking off I started you know
doing really well so meeting him and it
was a five year you know battle of five
and a half years we've know we've Noah
Maddox and through his ups and downs and
his days that he wanted to give up I
leaned on him with my training and
fighting you know trying to make it to
the UFC because millions of kids people
fighters all across the world are trying
that's what they wanted to do is become
the UFC champion and that was my goal
and Max's goal was just to walk me down
to the Octagon that was his sole goal
like he like for that he fought for that
you know I kept fighting for it I can't
wait to walk young girls were
accountable to each other yeah I mean
we're getting signed to the UFC you know
and bringing him there and seeing him
there Wow yeah just and then the UFC
caught wind of her story and granted him
to walk down to the octan when I fought
for my first world title I was like
hand-in-hand with him and I just fell
invincible that time like I was like
nothing can stop this this is this is
meant to be this is my man you know I
had like the most flawless performance I
was in the flow state and just
everything was lining up in my life and
you know so it was a great it was a
great night you know not only because I
want she was everyone was so happy and
what we finally I got to put the belt
around his waist and then make sure you
know we're you know after that a lot of
stuff happens you know a fast pace after
wearing a world title and we got
approached about doing a book and I had
you know I had a lot to my book and a
movie you know I kind of put on a you
know a halt for quite some time or
someone to focus on my career I was just
so dead set on not funny want to do that
but then you know with meeting with Rob
and and understanding kind of
entertainment and yeah you know I was a
kid that would just shot
superstar after winning you know when a
World Championship no this was all new
to me I want to slow it down and that
Rob came in and you know started talking
about the book and doing that and let me
to the right people and it's been a
great experience having you know you
know Maddox the story I told Rob that he
said this about some movie yeah no dude
I'm in t I'm just trying not to burst
and I'm still like blown away and kind
of surprising to me or kind of shocked
about it because I never thought that it
was gonna be something this big I
thought you know I mean like I look at
manager just doing something yeah just
like felt right never my spirit when I
got offered a lot of book and the movie
I'm like wow this is this is crazy and
then with the reason why I want to do it
push for because I feel like his fight
matters his his his his story needs to
be shared you know how many people are
affected by this horrible disease that
he members they lutely
they've lost family members or mothers
or brothers or sons or daughters through
this disease that this is a kid that you
know was just five years old you know
can go through any of that yeah is it
with the power of belief leaving himself
and having a purpose fun you know that
focus on something like myself like my
lighter in the tunnel was being a world
champion that's what kept me you know
from that you know getting hooked on
drugs from going down the wrong path
from just being a [ __ ] up was that mean
a world champion in our view I'm you
know our worlds collide our you know
crash course kind of like a pivotal time
with me Oh getting a lot of bar fights
and stabbed and other stuff and hem
going through chemo you know finally I
have cancer we kind of met that time
when there were low points and kind of
just raised up all the way to the top
became the best in the world you know
world champions and you know couldn't do
without that kid you know it's awesome
so credible how's he doing no he's great
he's 11 years old amazed my four years
in remission yeah so it says last year
you know August August 22nd would be his
fifth year admission so Wow hoping then
you know it surprised him with a huge
like and I just I want to get making
something just just special for a little
kid you know so awesome dude yeah so I'm
excited for this one this is the year
this is the year for it so uh you know
he's been to all my celebrations and
then my winnings you know this is his
his purser actual world title
championship this
his fight you know he'd be just he just
come he just conquered life at such an
early age and did it with such a
demeanor you know and a dedication that
inspired me to not give up my dreams I'm
like man I'm hurting so I choose to
fight this kid has to wake up every day
and fight for his life and I think
that's what you know made me at a time
that I could probably you know got
discouraged or had that you know yeah
when that comes in and pushes doubt in
your mind you know woulda just fall and
fell down and stay down but he helped me
get up and forever great for him and
here we are having him a book hopefully
a movie and you know it's fifty
remission next year exciting great
things man great things that's amazing
dude what an amazing story you guys
going on that journey together yeah I
think that's why everyone probably
everyone in the company has a vested
interest in you know what we do as far
as stories like that you know we all
know someone so it was someone in the
list cancer or someone that lost someone
like that or a touching story yeah I
think now in you know word in the prime
spot to to be the number one providers
or taking care of that yeah do a great
thing
[Music]